Paradise Island you're chairing the
Norwegian Nobel Committee what were the
main arguments for awarding this price
do I c'n well the major arguments for
awarding Ike in the price is that they
in fact have been a driving force when
it comes to disarmament issues in the
past year and I would like to mention
specifically the elements of the fact
that they have managed to create a
popular understanding and engagement for
these issues among ordinary people not
only experts and politicians and they
have also brought the debate forward by
focusing so heavily on the humanitarian
consequences of using nuclear arms the
humanitarian pledge is is part of this
initiative and they have also been a key
player in the work for the new club ban
treaty I would say those are the major
elements is the timing significant I
believe so because I do believe that
people do experience that they are
living in a more dangerous world that
the nuclear threat becomes more of a
reality by the way different states have
behaved in the past time but also it is
a deep tradition for the Peace Prize
Committee to award prices along this
these lines will it go over in history
as a controversial price you think I
don't believe so and I when I gave my
presentation and at the press conference
I underlined that in our mind this
cannot be a controversial price because
the goal of a nuclear free
world and of disarmament is such a
shared goal by almost all nations also
by the nuclear weapon nations because
they have made such a commitment by the
non-proliferation treaty that they shall
work for disarmament and the gold is a
nuclear weapon-free world but NATO
countries and others who are basing
their defence and deterrence and nuclear
weapons had said no so far in the UN and
the u.s. is actively actively lobbying
against it wouldn't that create some
sort of controversy in the in the
national governments and the political
environment well I hope it will
challenge them when I say encouragement
it is also a challenge but it is obvious
that a legal ban by an international
treaty will have to be part of a
solution but it is not a sufficient
solution in itself and exactly the
states you mentioned they have other
challenges and perhaps they will have to
start a more active disarmament policy
before they can enter a ban treaty that
is understandable but it is also a fact
that the non-proliferation states they
haven't been active enough they have not
proceeded to speed on the obligations
they have under the treaty so if there
is a criticism in this price it is on
that level and the treaty is just one
step of the strategy so you could say
that a potential element of controversy
is actually enhancing the public debate
yes perhaps and also reminding everyone
of their obligations you considered the
way the committee which is behind the
icon it's actually working I mean how
significant it is and and
the methods they're using well we have
considered I think in the reasons that I
read today we have given a description
of the strategy that they use and the
way they approach these problems that is
sort of three folded you know working
for stigma prohibition and arms
reduction that has been a central part
of the reasoning why they were awarded
the prize